it is more dangerous than ever to drive
on County roads and freeways that
according to the union representing
Nevada State Police thank you for
joining us at 11 O'Brien Loftus I'm
Denise Valdez now they say there's
simply not a Troopers to keep up with
demand but the academy that would help
staff them with new Troopers is falling
behind too Ryan mathie joins us now live
just outside of NSP headquarters with
what this means for our safety
yeah Denise Bryan this state agency has
been operating with less than half a
staff for years even the governor
admitting that they don't get enough
money to stick around and according to a
union representative for this area to
fill all those gaps the academy becoming
somewhat desperate to keep those willing
to stay
before Troopers get here
they go here we lost somebody day one of
the County arrest told by a member and
then we lost the second one just a few
days later but Wayne dice a Nevada
police union representative says not
enough Cadets are making it through the
Academy's six-month long program It
prepares them for Road Patrol there were
only 18 graduates seven academies ago 22
graduates just two academies ago now
just nine are on track to graduate in
this current class down from 13 when it
started nine weeks ago and we're seeing
people push forward and going through
training again and being retrained again
and and that's concerning several
members more and more chances that
typically don't happen he says the main
reason for leaving we train people and
the sheriff and the police departments
hire them away from us because they can
get a 30 raise as soon as they leave
even Governor sis lacked during the
politics now interview agreeing wages
are too low when compared to other
agencies and with state Troopers already
scarce driver's safety is taking the hit
seen this week with back-to-back deadly
crashes that took 15 minutes for
somebody to start responding just
because we don't have enough bodies out
there working so should more Troopers be
expected soon you know they've got a lot
of weeks ahead of them still and do I
think we lose more we probably will
now he does that it is an intensive
course and all those physical
requirements do play partly into some
people's decision to leave early
reporting live outside NSP headquarters
Ryan Matthey 8 News Now